there are a thousand insects in each
container gime Tribble anto is releasing
a quarter of a million mosquitoes into
the wild these insects were bred in a
laboratory and the team hope to use them
to stop deadly dengue fever from
spreading cool a paintball mosquito
we're not attacking dengue fever
directly instead we're going after the
carriers of the disease if we reduce the
mosquito population it will have a
direct impact on the spread of dengue
nothing
two million anti dengue mosquitoes a
week grow in this laboratory in Sao
Paulo state only male larvae are allowed
to develop they don't bite but they are
deadly to other mosquitoes when they're
released in piracicaba they're going to
find the females in the wild so all the
wild females that are living in a house
underneath our bed what they will do is
they will copulate with them and they're
going to transmit the lethal gene to all
their progeny so the babies when they're
born in the wild they will die during
their development the testing zone in
Peru ki khabar is around two hours drive
from Sao Paulo it has a population of
5,500 for the first time ever
genetically engineered insects have been
released into a residential area
Brazil's liberal laws make this possible
that's how this is all good for us or
they wouldn't have allowed it Darwin JD
Pickett bangee is a huge problem here
but I honestly don't know whether it
justifies such a project maybe more
research needs to be done first mize is
doable previous field tests predicted
the mosquito population would go down by
eighty percent there are no official
figures in PT ki khabar guillame travel
Otto and his team gather eggs to
determine the success of the project
staff at the local hospital say some
progress has been made us men them into
the basis on average we used to have
four new cases of dengue a days you know
this number has now dropped
significantly we have high hopes for the
project I'm only a vaccine against
dengue fever is expected to take at
least three years to develop in the
meantime laboratory mosquitoes are being
used as a weapon against the dangerous
virus